[Music]
hey
we are the impractical jokers and this
week you'll see us on hot ones truth or
dab and of course sal
i brought help but uh i'm gonna try not
to use it and to my family i love you
he's going to use it he's going to use
it
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
truth or dab the hot one special where
we give our guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last ab and today i'm very excited
to welcome james murray salvolcano and
brian quinn better known as merc sal and
q of the impractical jokers you can
catch new episodes every thursday on
truetv and on the truetv app guys
welcome to the show yes all right so
excited so excited dude well before we
begin let me explain what's going on in
front of you you guys have a series of
wings they've all been doused in various
versions of the last app i have a set of
deeply personal potentially awkward
questions for each of you and when i ask
you a question you have a choice answer
it honestly or escape the truth by
eating a death wave
in q yeah we're going to start with you
right all right let me know i'll see you
on the other side you know the
punishments on impractical jokers they
can range from tests of endurance like
the time that you're handcuffed to a
mime for 24 hours just into straight up
social torture what for you has been the
most traumatic punishment in your
experience
i can answer five answers to that
question the one with the x's on the
children's i remember that one classic
that was brutal uh one i mean do i get
out of if i give four answers do i get
out of all of these no that's not no
but go ahead let it fly universal when
you had to pull the emergency that
looked like it was annoying but that's a
good catch because that's that's a ride
that normally takes 45 minutes so what
happened was on the universal tram ride
uh they have the emergency brake where
you pull it and stops the ride it's the
tram ride through the back lot normally
that ride is 45 minutes long i made that
ride two hours and 15 minutes for people
and people were threatening me
threatening me one guy stood up pointed
me goes when this ride ends i'm gonna
find you and kill you you're ruining my
vacation stuff like that and they just
had me stop it over and over there's a
lot going on i'm realizing maybe we're
not as good friends as i thought
all right moving on to murr yes murr
you're up next what's the most set up
you've ever felt during an episode i'm
kind of partial to the time that you
thought you were competing in a
bodybuilding
competition walked into a room and then
we're face to face with your childhood
crush danica mckellar while you're oiled
up and in a speedo i'll tell you what
about the punishment so what's maybe not
on tv is that they held me in this giant
room with guys that were actually
lifting weights all greased up
themselves they're twice my size and
they piped in the sounds on speaker of
an actual bodybuilding competition so
keep in mind that i was all greased up
my nipples were out and i do have pointy
nipples as evidenced by the fact that
for today for the hot ones i wore
pasties
so you wouldn't see my nipples because
there's pointy nipples so i felt
mortified already and the second before
i turned the door hand i was like what
if it's something different right but
never in a million years did i think it
was danica mckeller all of our childhood
crushes from the wonder years and i
walked in she's sitting there looking
spectacular in her gown
and i i walked into the corner like a
weirdo i walked in the
he also just told us by the way in the
green room that his wife had to apply
the nipple covers today to which we said
why why was your wife i said it's all
for minister nipple coverage you can
though no if this this show's not filmed
in 3d but if it were and i took these
off wow you could cut glass with those
numbers
they're kind of poking through
they are though i need i need
all right yeah that was the most set up
i ever felt in my entire life
all right selling on to you i refuse to
answer
[Laughter]
what's the closest you've ever been to
getting punched in the face messing with
the wrong one during the shoot uh yes so
you know the tkts booth in times square
it's like people line up all day like
for a couple hours to get really
discounted broadway tickets day of and
it usually has a line that snakes like a
thousand people on it so i cut that line
and a war vet i only know that because i
only know he's a war vet because he was
in the outfit he was a civil war fan
and he told me but he was getting like
furious with me and so he called over
security that i cut him and then when
security came over i i just kind of was
like i don't know who this man is i
don't know actually i said i'm with him
i said i'm with him i don't know why
he's treating him in this way and the
guy just lost it and just grabbed me he
was like 70. yeah he was he was he
grabbed me and he strangled me like this
like literally like homer
but for real i was just like
but it was you know he was he had seen
some action
so i just kind of i just kind of waited
it out seeing you i just got to see you
guys triggered a flashback
all right well moving on here to round
number two and here we'll heat things up
a little bit
murr
yes sir you know one of the marks of the
mega success of jokers has been that
it's launched a handful of spin-offs
including joker's wild dinner party
inside jokes and a practical joker's
after party which one of those spin-offs
would you say was most for the bag okay
we'll take the money what's the most for
the money and run oh inside joke dude
can i change my answer
you are not you're a disaster oh it's
hot
you think in my defense i didn't know
what for the background do you think
you're on cold wings cold ones
oh john what did you do to me
on the first bite you don't know about
art we love the comedy wait you're going
to do that
i was going to try a whole lot
the guy who brought my lantern i'm like
don't drink the milk you can sell oh
you may have to put it to the test
because now we're moving the focus over
to you
you know we were briefly we were briefly
network mates
[Laughter]
we were briefly network mates and for us
the extremely short-lived hot ones the
game show and i know the relationship is
good and blah blah blah blah blah blah
be real
what is
the single dumbest creative note you've
ever gotten from an executive at true tv
[Laughter]
so
you messed up he's happy to get to this
yeah
i'm sorry i'm tired
i'm tired
what
i'm physically dying right now drool i
am dying i'm the first one that was
number one
yeah yeah but you know what what is
wrong all right all right all right um
don't eat the wig
let me just let me buy it here we go i'm
gonna be joining the party okay
oh this is gonna be fun i've thought
about this one for a very long time it's
happening this is gonna be fun to watch
up close i'm so happy i'm here for this
it's hot right away
that's for sure
the whole wingman hauling
[Music]
[Music]
totally normal totally normal great murr
you're doing great you're not i feel
like i'm collapsing inside oh oh there
it is
oh yeah
you have drone
mouth i'm collapsing the hiccups
yeah hiccups are
one i don't know but it happens to me
sometimes too i understand i understand
exactly what you're going through oh
[ __ ] dude
the noises coming out of you or really
something i'm not good with heat i
should have mentioned it
got to my lantern
all right
this is not what i
just you guys
who are really
really making me nervous all right don't
be don't be nervous because all you have
to do answer the question honestly
yeah
you guys are a multi-hyphenate group in
fact myrrh over here has written four
novels i'm curious have you read
literally any of them can you give us a
30 second book report on the sunday
times best seller awakened
let's just start with number one
just start with number one
to read i i i read an early draft of it
and gave him notes in 2003 a long time
ago you never read the final product it
was something about a there was a locust
and a train car or something like that
there was something like like he sent me
all four books i didn't even crack the
spine yeah
he gave me one of those
he gave me one of his books backstage at
one of our shows and uh he wrote this
christmas a nice person yeah he gave me
his own book for christmas by the way
just so everybody knows that uh and then
i left it at the theater and i felt so
bad that i called the theater and i had
them ship it to me
uh and now i'm realizing that's a waste
of money
oh don't touch your eyes that was a bad
oh yeah don't touch it you're late
start at one [ __ ]
it's coming undone yeah yeah and maybe
just take a bite
don't eat the whole thing
oh [ __ ] me what do i do about the eye
situation
[Music]
i'm coming in with emergency milk
thank you so much i feel like maybe i
will look better with all the white for
my eyes
i feel like a total feeler
i do like a failure to all you guys i
wash everything people get to the end
they put extra on the end
they don't even drink the milk all the
water i'm drinking the milk whoa she was
going back in
i'm sure it'll kick in but it hasn't
kicked in yet
but i know i saw the moment i kicked it
on you guys so i'm waiting here it gets
hotter enough
does it get hot come on in dumb i should
not have touched it does the more i eat
the hotter it gets or is this like yeah
that's kind of how it goes
you know like life well i don't know if
there's like only a certain level of oh
the more i talk the more the air is my
taste buds and the more it heats it up
that's the least hot
they're all the kind of the same they're
all kind of the same pod
all right mark i want to be good for you
guys
you're doing so good you guys are doing
so good we just want to be good for sure
we're moving on you you're doing so well
yeah i'm not crying or anything like
what the hell i have a constitution i
have a weak constitution
this is a double cross no it's hot if
you guys sean if you guys want to trade
paddles you can
[Music]
okay here it goes here we go
all right sal now it's under the tongue
moving the attention back to you all
right so to open up this next round
we're gonna lean on your finance degree
from st john's university okay so you
might as well never have so focus focus
through this all right because i will
not repeat the question okay
attacks placed on a hot sauce company
with an upward sloping supply curve and
a downward sloping demand curve a
causes the equilibrium quantity of the
good to increase or b affects them
[Laughter]
b affects the welfare of buyers of the
good but not the welfare of sellers see
what you do causes an increase in the
effective price paid by buyers d creates
a burden that is born entirely by
consumers it is c causes increasing the
effective price paid by buyers
did it go up your nose yes oh that's the
part
you were the senior vice presidential
securities for finance
get your head out of your ass sound that
was mvp and it was some mutual funds
[Music]
on over to you one of my favorite bits
of yours was the april fool's day prank
where you ran a bogus campaign
for congress i'm curious
which one of your real life political
takes do you think would be least
popular with jokers and first
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
i have some interesting thoughts about
wealth
cheers to you sean
one bite bird just one bite don't go
don't be a hero don't oh i eat it at all
i mean the wing is delicious
wing is delicious all right q before we
move on to the final round i have one
more question for you oh i know that
you're a huge fan of the wu tank yeah
between raequan uh rizza ghostface and
method man who's the most overrated mc
and why oh
yeah okay
so i just jump right
and everything they do is quite frankly
wonderful it's just an honor to be
living on the same
i gotta i gotta meet someone after this
you're gonna be yeah it's a bad move
oh my god
it's the particles that go up the nose
right yeah that really create the
problem
you know that's a good rule in life in
general it's like um it's like a like a
piece of chicken skin got up my nose and
it's just burning its way throughout
like the aliens yeah like burning its
way into my brain
well the good news is we're approaching
the finish line we're on to the final
round dom is there an extra wing i'll
take one in solidarity oh my god we're
going through it yes they've been going
through it i feel like all of my lips
are breaking out in herpes again i'm
here today
i'm here to join the party all right we
are on to the final round and this is a
question that i have for all of you guys
since you've recently re-upped on
contract time for a show that has been a
marketing network staple for nine years
i'm just curious how much do you guys
make perhaps
come on
three or four it doesn't matter
yeah it's all the same
[Music]
i love you a lot i love screaming that's
great
i don't know what is in it what is in it
that makes it so spicy the pepperoni the
hot sauce
the pepper x pepper x
cherry pepper grown by
smoking ed curry
who grew the carolina reaper
and that has blessed us with this this
isn't for human consumption come on no
this is crazy i can't do it no argument
there
it's getting better
it's getting better oh murray you look
like you're downright enjoying it
getting better now now i'm using my body
temperature's rising to 114 degrees so
i'm okay with it
well there you have it another truth oh
my god
impractical jokers thursdays on truetv
and on the true tv app
thank you sean i'd like to say thank you
but i can't this was a true honor really
really really always wanted to do it
thank you so much
thank you so much
[Music]
yeah pretty hard brother you [ __ ] did
so this is hotter than the ones in case
you see even it feels like
oh did you do that you did it yeah i
could do this with every guest afterward
like you did so good bunny come on
thanks for doing it
you guys did great
buddy there's nothing you could just
blast in your mouth to get it to stop
hey what's going on hot ones fans we
brought the heat to the freezer aisle
with our hot ones boneless chicken bites
and you smashed sales records and all of
our wildest expectations so what did we
do we made more that's right we are in
with five new flavors of hot ones
boneless chicken bites and five new ways
for you to bring hot ones home from the
classic to the classic garlic fresno
edition to the los calientes trio of
flavor verde rojo barbacoa visit hot
oneschallenge.com for more information
and to find a store near you hot ones
boneless chicken bites you're in the hot
seat now